hi everyone just a quick more of a news
update in the air world which is the
following
Pantene launches sh e the search human
equalizer to shine a light on bias in
search so Pantene the kind of cosmetic
corporation launches this thing which is
supposed to correct your search and it's
introduced here in this YouTube video
which as you can see down here has a 400
likes has 3.5 K dislikes and of course
comments are disabled so that's kind of
already weird let's let's say weird if
you go to the website here that they
made basically let me refresh this and
you can see see the intro they say let's
take the bias out of search so if you
search for greatest engineers you'll get
all men if you search for school girl
you'll get like this kind of sexualized
images a free search for Asian women in
Spanish the same so basically they have
a browser extension that modifies your
search results do that for example
schoolgirl looks like this of course I
don't know if if I were to do this I
would actually let people explore the
search box right here
but of course they I want you to
download this extension and so to me
what the interesting part is how do how
does this work
so you're asked to install a Chrome
extension which I won't do but basically
down here they say view the terms that
sh e is equalizing if you click on that
you get to a list so
very much seems like this is absolutely
manual handcrafted work because there's
a lot of work in kind of correcting bias
in for example in search in machine
learning and so on these approaches
usually have some data-driven approach
that actually will will change the
models or and so on or will rerun based
on some kind of learned input but this
here is simply a list of terms for
example famous actor famous athletes and
so on that it will then kind of Arirang
and I'm pretty sure this is just human
manual labor someone comes up with a new
term like oh this term we should you can
actually flag yourself in the Chrome
extension so they say here I've locked
this search you can there's a button so
you can suggest one and they will say oh
yeah okay that is really not biased or
that is really biased
well now Arirang the search results for
you I mean academically this is a
terrible idea absolutely terrible
because how are you gonna do this like
manually replace every single sir it's
like I don't know it reminds a bit of
Newspeak but yeah this approach is
doomed to fail and of course it's just a
company trying to sell you stuff it's
not and this is not a this is a PR gag
not really trying to do anything
anything state-of-the-art or meaningful
or even effective right if you search a
little different thing than this it will
still show you that old kind of result
yeah so from the terms you can also
pretty clearly see where they come from
they have their own name to have pantene
I didn't see this yet
if pantie in here yeah so yeah if you
want less biased search results for
these exact terms then install the
extension I do not recommend
and you do so but I would like them to
take on one more query that I came up
with as pretty pretty biased I found and
that's the most dangerous criminals all
men goodbye